Spider-Man Homecoming actors cheering
Hey Buddy, what's up?
How ya doin?
I'm Spider-Man!
Nice to meet you
What's your name?
Nicholas, nice to meet you!
So do you like Batman better than Spider-Man?
Nods yes...
awwwww what!
why's that?
what's better about Batman
Poo-Poo
Doesn't really make sense but okay!
That's awesome buddy!
oh my God I was so great.
I mean of course the little kid wearing Batman
on his shirt probably like Batman more than
anybody else, but I just love that they kept
this on camera.
This is a great deal like Batman better than
Spider-Man oh yeah sick burn.
If you can understand what the little kids
said he actually said pooh-pooh that was his
reason to give Tom Holland for why Batman
is better than Spiderman you doesn't really
make sense, but sure buddy that's great you
haven't seen it recently.
A lot of the Marvel movies have been visiting
children's hospitals is called like the lollipop
theater thing is based like a charity just
brings movie stars.
You know in costume Spiderman here to see
sick children to associate really cool charity
and actually did the same thing a little while
ago.
You may seen pictures from it like here Tom
Holland visiting children in hospital just
getting them super pumped up about Spiderman
is like the best thing ever.
They actually did it with the Thor Ragnarok
cast Chris Hemsworth Tom Hiddleston while
they were in Australia filming the movie they
went to see hospital shortly took Thor's hammer
to let the kids hit Tom Hiddleston with the
hammer.
Hey buddy!
Do you need a hand?
We got your back if you do
right here with you man.
This is Loki here and Thor
What is it like getting to be a superhero and supervillain?
Well, it is very cool. Especially when I face this
particular supervillain very mischievous tricks
and so you gotta watch him, he's a big shifty
and went with brothers, not in real life
so as is the new trend for you know big movies
like this to do outreach go visit children
is because little kids idolize superheroes
in of these big comic book films are made
for families to so it's one of my favorite
new trends from like these big corporate entities
that you traditionally wouldn't view in such
a positive light, but one of the most fun
things for people like Chris Pratt to do is
dress up his star Lord and go visit children
hospitals even did it last year with Chris
Evans because it was the New England Patriots
and the Seahawks so they were like on opposite
sides like you have star Lord rooting for
one team you have Capt. America rooting for
the other, so they turned to this big charity
thing where they both ended up dressing up
in costume and going to visit children see
you guys can let me know like what you think
about like these new superhero movies doing
a lot of charity outraged you like it that
they're going to visit children in hospitals
do you think they should be doing something
else I feel like this is probably one of the
biggest reasons why people like Robert Downey
Junior and like the other actors that have
been around for long time continue to play
the characters because they get to do stuff
like this, so that you the impact people's
lives in a much more real tangible way like
you know you see a really awesome movie you
get really jazzed up about it like you see
your superheroes the really like doing stuff
it's really cool, but when you actually get
to meet them in real life, especially when
you're a little kid it just so far above and
beyond it is cool as this is there's a whole
bunch of other Spiderman stuff happening recently.
So you know who Lynn Manwell is he just like
of a fairly notable actor associated with
Hamilton he does a lot of other stuff.
He said that he really wants to play carnage
in the Spider-Man movies like the Marvel Spiderman
movies so I'll be doing a video about that
later.
I wanted to like my Kevin fight he Marvel
versus DC versus X-Men video next just a good
one due to Spiderman videos back to back but
be sure to subscribe to get everything and
let me know if there any Spider-Man comic
book storylines you want me to do videos for
because I was in the movies have their own
thing that they're doing.
But they tend to weave in a lot of comic book
stuff like you see Ned leads here who is the
future hobgoblin in the Spider-Man universe.
So even though I don't think were gonna be
seeing a lot of hobgoblin stuff in this for
Spider-Man homecoming movie they're not can
a completely ignore the fact that he will
eventually become that character so you like
this really awesome friend of Peter Parker's
in high school that eventually becomes one
of his big villains so they kind of doing
that with the entire Spider-Man homecoming
cast almost everybody is playing a really
big character and just a follow-up on the
maryjane Cynthia stuff she's been adamant
over and over about how she is not playing
Mary Jane is like that be really cool but
that's not me at all in the movie, so you
can let me know if you think that she's totally
lying because marble has a gun to her head.
But they actually have a team of people that
go around and censor people who are working
for them so they don't spoil stuff for the
movie or do you think she's telling the truth
in the character she's playing some it is
totally different like Michelle Gonzales was
like a really bad ass Spider-Man character
but obviously not anywhere near maryjane and
I was forgot.
There's a trailer rumor, so a lot of you been
asking me about a potential trailer dropping
in the next couple of weeks like them attaching
Spider-Man homecoming two Rogue one.
So I me will find out like if it drops it
drops and if not, then the price drop during
the Super Bowl.
But if I hear anything that all totally do
a video about it obviously there's footage
all totally do a video about it to Sonu Kevin
fight he Marvel versus DC posting next that'll
probably be Thursday morning what you guys
wait for that to post you can click here for
Tom Holland talking about being in the avengers
and Spider-Man movies and you can click here
to learn all about the Dr. strange sequel
the stories I think they should do thank you
so much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight